Archer - close your eyes and think of
them
happy I'll think of a memory you
associate with you you now consider the
most paint there for your eyes now open
your eyes
this device extracts the actual memory
from the array and displayed it before
you
machine it's incredible pure unfiltered
truth
[Music]
this is a terrible loss I just wanted to
say I'm truly sorry I am how did you
know Gordon save my life he was found
dead in his office with gunshots in the
wall contrast no bullet wounds he was
working with a lot of troubled people we
need to find out what happened to Gordon
it's the least I could do
they can't see your memories but I could
see the memories of those near you who
are you working for his widow I know you
saw him that night
can I help you yes Alison Alison is dead
you think they're hiding something there
are people looking for you if one man
has been murdered got bigger things to
worry about what cannot get out about go
understand what do you want from me I
want to ask you questions about Gordon
done get out lines get thing for ugly
Luther adverse effects the Machine time
collapse loosen ation do you know who
this is
Martin husband wine
I think I know who killed Tori I would
hate if I found out that your life
you have something you wish you can
forget try put it out we do
you